Abby and I met a long time ago 10 years
ago now we met at a book club now a book
club that focused on queer stories you
know once we actually started dating
Susan quit her job
she moved out of her house moved into my
apartment in Bombay and we got a dog
for same-sex couples like Aditi and
Susan getting married in India was once
a far-fetched idea now they are part of
a group petitioning the Supreme Court
for the right to marry I think very
strongly and very much so that we're
ready and I I do feel like Society is
ready as well in being petitioners here
we're trying to do our little bit in
being in being brave ourselves
but India remains a deeply conservative
society and the Court's ruling on
marriage equality will be watched
closely around the world
the question really is this will the
world's largest democracy open the door
to a new lgbtq Revolution
a couple of years ago when we decided to
have
children is when we
thought that marriage would be a logical
next step for us
in in doing that in having and raising a
child now we realize more so the lack of
a lot of things that we don't have today
uh legal rights over each other
the ability to you know have a bank
account to own assets together to be a
legal parent to a child
fight for lgbtq rights has come a long
way thanks in part to a combination of
Grassroots lobbying and aggressive
litigation
a favorable judgment now would more than
double the number of people globally
with marriage equality rights
eventually cementing inheritance
adoption and other protections to 1.4
billion Indians
and lawyers are optimistic
they have strong legal grants for
extending basic protections to the lgbtq
community we really believe this to be
an issue of fundamental rights that have
to be guaranteed to all people and we
feel that there is judicial precedent
and there is room in the special
Marriage Act to interpret the grant of
these rights so we are we're it's early
days where we are cautiously hopeful and
optimistic
a positive ruling on same-sex marriage
in India would have implications across
the world including in countries like
Thailand and Greece where similar
debates are gaining momentum
a positive court order would offer them
social protections that could change
their lives
had we been
a straight couple this wouldn't even
have been a conversation it probably
would have happened
um
far more easily for me at a very
personal level
I expect the highest court in my country
to recognize me as an equal citizen
some members of the LGBT community say
marriage rights will lead the foundation
to a more Equitable Society
Krishnan is a Contemporary Indian artist
the ruling for same-sex marriage is very
important it equalizes you and the eyes
of the law same-sex marriage is the
first step but the next step which is
actual freedom is when there are civil
rights so that you can be partners
couples and you don't have to get
married because getting married does put
you in a box
and some people will would present yet
another boxing given to you I do
sumant lived through a different time
when being openly gay was extremely red
you grow up thinking that you're deeply
wrong now that's what's imposed On You
by the world
until recently a Draconian law known as
section 377 criminalized sex between men
it was only finally repealed in 2018.
you know
the very fact that there was an article
377 you are inherently
a deviant and you were illegal and you
were not in a space of strength or power
you were always on the back foot and
anyone who wanted to take advantage of
that could at any point of time yeah and
that's what I grew up with to all my
life
many Indians still object to
homosexuality on Maori ground
in fact Indian government has told the
court it opposes same-sex marriage and
In Pockets of the country especially
outside of bigger cities the
consequences of living openly can be
severe from harassment and social
isolation to frightening vulnerability
to sexual abuse
in our petitions in the high court are
the opposition has typically and
traditionally been that this is not a
part of Indian culture first of all I
don't think it's something that outside
Indian culture I believe Indian culture
to be very tolerant and I believe the
Indian people to be very rights oriented
and to be understanding of everyone's
rights
you know the crazy thing is and that
India culturally
is very fluid very ambiguous very
all-ambracing and I can tell you that
from experience up the Indian mind space
is a very
it's a very uh it's a very lovely space
it's a very accepting space
regardless of the outcome in the Supreme
Court Aditi and Susan will need marriage
equality will come to India sooner or
later
there's been such a vast change in
everything and we're immensely lucky
um to be able to witness that and you
know there are challenges for sure a lot
of us grew up feeling that nowhere never
going to come out
um and it's that's a debilitating fear
and I'm hoping that petitions like this
communities like this movements like
this is going to ensure that people in
this country don't have that fear
anymore
thank you